I don't want to start a flame war, although somebody told me that's good for viewership. I would recommend Scala. But yeah, I'm Alexis King, and I work on GHC, Haskell Compiler. Special guest, Jose Valim. He is the creator of the Elixir language. Allegedly. Allegedly? Allegedly. What does that mean?
我不想挑起骂战，尽管有人告诉我这对收视率有好处。我推荐 Scala。不过，我是 Alexis King，我在 GHC（Haskell 编译器）工作。特邀嘉宾是 Jose Valim。他是 Elixir 语言的创造者。据称。据称？据称。这是什么意思？
Who knows? It's a panna cotta, and the sauce, I think, is passion fruit. I'm interested in type theory, dependent types, functional programming in general. I would like to create programs which works. I like to create programs that works. That's a quote. Well, maybe that'll be the cold open right there. If you like Ruby syntax more, use Elixir.
谁知道呢？这是一份意式奶冻，酱汁我想是百香果的。我对类型理论、依赖类型以及整体的函数式编程都很感兴趣。我想编写能正常运行的程序。我喜欢编写能正常运行的程序。这是一句名言。好吧，也许这就会成为开场白。如果你更喜欢 Ruby 的语法，那就用 Elixir。
If you like Prolog syntax more, you don't care about syntax, use Erlang. I'm always so worried whenever I finish this that I'm going to look down and it's not going to be recording. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 133, recorded on June 6, 2023. My name is Connor, and on today's episode, we interview attendees and speakers from the Lambda Days 2023 conference that took place on June 5th to June 6th in Krakow, Poland. We interview in this episode, Toby Pfeiffer, Kim Huizing, Alexis King, Jose Valim, Andor Penz, and Pierre Stritzinger. This is part one of a two-part episode. All right, we are here live. First time we're ever doing a live interview on ADSP, the podcast. We're here with Tobi Pfeiffer. Tobi, I mean, I know where you're from and what communities you operate in, but the people do not. Introduce yourself briefly.
如果你更喜欢 Prolog 的语法，或者你不在乎语法，那就用 Erlang。每次录完这个节目，我都非常担心一低头发现它根本没在录音。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 133 期，录制于 2023 年 6 月 6 日。我是 Connor，今天的节目中，我们采访了 2023 年 6 月 5 日至 6 日在波兰克拉科夫举办的 Lambda Days 2023 大会的与会者和演讲者。本期节目我们采访了 Toby Pfeiffer、Kim Huizing、Alexis King、Jose Valim、Andor Penz 和 Pierre Stritzinger。这是分两集的节目的第一部分。好的，我们现在进行现场直播。这是我们第一次在 ADSP 播客上做现场采访。我们和 Tobi Pfeiffer 在一起。Tobi，我知道你来自哪里，在哪些社区活动，但听众们不知道。简要介绍一下你自己吧。
Hi, my name is Tobi. I'm from Berlin in Germany. I'm mostly active in the Elixir community. I'm known for Benchy there, which is like the benchmarking library, and otherwise operate in the Ruby community a lot. I maintain SimpleCoff, which is a code coverage library, and I run the Ruby user group in Berlin for like almost 11 years. And so yeah, that's what I do. So you went from Ruby to Elixir. Why the switch? Should people, should everyone in Ruby switch to Elixir? Although you still operate in both communities. It's a great question. Not everybody should switch, but I personally... Ruby is a lot of very fancy stuff, very fancy meta programming, very many things that go haywire. And especially, let's say, I don't want to start a flame war, although somebody told me that's good for viewership.
嗨，我叫 Tobi。我来自德国柏林。我主要活跃于 Elixir 社区。我在那里以开发 Benchy（即基准测试库）而闻名，此外也在 Ruby 社区活动很多。我维护着 SimpleCoff（一个代码覆盖率库），并且运营柏林 Ruby 用户组将近 11 年了。所以，是的，这就是我在做的事情。所以你从 Ruby 转到了 Elixir。为什么要转变？人们，每个人都应该从 Ruby 转到 Elixir 吗？虽然你现在在这两个社区都还在活动。这是一个很好的问题。并不是每个人都应该转换，但我个人……Ruby 有很多非常花哨的东西，非常花哨的元编程，以及很多容易出岔子的事情。尤其是，比方说，我不想挑起骂战，尽管有人告诉我这对收视率有好处。
Yeah, start a flame war if you want. Go for it. So Rails, and especially ActiveRecord, has a lot of this magic going on with all of those callbacks going back and forth, back and forth. And so it's so hard to figure out where a bug is. And like I saw Alex here, and like the function programming paradigm, and also the way that they design, for instance, their database layer, Acto, as being much more explicit about what happens. So like in Acto, you've got to go and you actually have a repo instance. And every time you make a query to the database, you've actually got to go to the repo and be like repo do this thing and so it's very explicit like where sql queries happen and all of that and i just enjoyed that and the architecture and the thinking you know much more plus ruby is still not great at you know parallel programming like ruby has now
如果你想挑起骂战，那就挑吧。尽管放马过来。所以 Rails，尤其是 ActiveRecord，有很多这样的魔法在发生，各种回调函数来回交织。因此要找出 Bug 在哪里真是太难了。就像我看到 Alex 一样，以及函数式编程范式，还有他们设计数据库层 Acto 的方式，对于发生的事情要明确得多。所以在 Acto 里，你必须去实际拥有一个仓库（repo）实例。每次你向数据库发起查询时，你实际上都必须去找仓库，就像是说“repo，执行这个操作”。所以 sql 查询在哪里发生之类的非常明确，我真的很喜欢这一点，还有架构和思维方式，更不用说 Ruby 在并行编程方面依然不那么出色——Ruby 现在有了
guilds and whatnot but like you know it's the year of like 2023 right and you know alex and erlang like the actor model is just so great and I always wanted to work with the actor model and Elixir gave me that nice way into it that's not as hardcore as Erlang. It's like a little bit of Ruby, a little bit of like the Ruby abstractions, let's say, but I can still use the full power of the Beam VM which I'm very happy about. I just realized too
协程（guilds）之类别的，但你知道的，现在已经是 2023 年了，你知道 Alex 和 Erlang 那种 Actor 模型是如此之棒，我一直想用 Actor 模型工作，而 Elixir 为我提供了一个很好的切入点，它没有 Erlang 那么硬核。它有点像 Ruby，带有一点 Ruby 的抽象，比方说，但我仍然可以使用 Beam 虚拟机（VM）的全部威力，对此我非常高兴。我刚刚还意识到
Jose Valim is standing like three feet behind you. We'll talk to Jose in a sec. So we're here at Lambda Days 2023. It's a functional programming conference. First time I've been here, but I talked to you. It sounds like you're a speaker this year. It sounds like you've spoken in the past.
Jose Valim 就站在你身后三英尺的地方。我们一会儿跟 Jose 聊聊。我们现在在 2023 年 Lambda Days 大会现场。这是一个函数式编程大会。这是我第一次来这里，但我跟你聊过。听起来你今年是演讲嘉宾。听起来你过去也做过演讲。
How many times have you been to Lambda Days before? Exactly. I mean, totally two times. This year and the last time that I spoke, which is like four years ago or something, I think, where I talked about Benchy. But it's a great conference. And what I love about it
你以前去过多少次 Lambda Days？确切地说，总共两次。今年以及上一次我做演讲的时候，大概是四年前左右吧，当时我讲的是 Benchy。但这真是个很棒的大会。我喜欢它的一点是
is that all of the different languages go together here. Because sometimes I say, I've been to so many Ruby conferences, I've been to quite a bit of LXD conferences, and at some point, some of the topics repeat, or they have overlap, or they're almost the same. But then it's so cool for me to go watch a Haskell talk
这里汇聚了所有不同的语言。因为有时我说，我参加过那么多 Ruby 社区大会，参加过相当多的 Elixir 大会，在某种程度上，有些话题会重复，或者它们有重叠，或者几乎一模一样。但对我来说，去听一场 Haskell 的演讲
or go watch a Clojure talk and see how does this community think, what are they thinking about? How do they operate? So for instance, one thing that I've also heard you say yesterday is that, you know, from the Clojure community, I learned to focus on data, you know, it's all about data. And that changed the way I think about programming. And so I love going out there and like, taking bits and pieces of like from other communities to change the way that I think about programming. Yeah, absolutely. And you just finished giving literally 10 minutes ago, your talk that you just presented. Tell us the title that I think about programming. Yeah, absolutely. And you just finished giving, literally 10 minutes ago, your talk that you just presented.
或者去听一场 Clojure 的演讲，看看这个社区是怎么思考的，他们在想什么，他们是怎么运作的，这真是太酷了。比如，我昨天还听到你说的另一件事是，从 Clojure 社区，我学会了专注于数据，一切都围绕着数据。这改变了我对编程的看法。所以我喜欢走出去，从其他社区汲取点点滴滴，来改变我对编程的思考方式。是的，绝对如此。就在刚刚，大概 10 分钟前，你刚刚结束了你的演讲。告诉我们那个标题——我想关于编程的。是的，绝对如此。就在刚刚，大概 10 分钟前，你刚刚结束了你的演讲。
Tell us the title. I was there. It was fantastic. But this is a podcast, so folks aren't going to be listening to it during this podcast, but we'll leave a link when it goes online. What can people expect from the talk you just gave? Thank you very much. So the talk is titled Stories in Open Source,
告诉我们标题。我在现场。太棒了。但这毕竟是个播客，听众们在听这个播客时不会去听那个演讲，但等它上线时我们会附上链接。大家能从你刚刚的演讲中期待些什么呢？非常感谢。所以演讲的标题是《开源中的故事》，
and it basically goes through my story in open source, like how I started out in open source and was very frustrating, and it talks about why was it frustrating, what was bad, and then how I finally got into open source, what worked for me, and all the benefits I took from that, but also what I learned about open source project management, or also just in general working with people and tries to tell the story and give people a good piece of knowledge and advice so that they can either maintain their open source projects better, contribute to open source projects, or essentially also whatever other volunteer work they do,
它基本上回顾了我在开源领域的经历，比如我是如何开始接触开源的，当时非常受挫。它谈到了为什么会受挫，有哪些不好的地方，然后我是如何最终真正进入开源世界的，什么对我有用，以及我从中获得的所有好处，还有我所了解到的开源项目管理，或者仅仅是关于如何与人共事，它试图讲述这个故事，并为人们提供好的知识和建议，以便他们能够更好地维护自己的开源项目，为开源项目做贡献，或者本质上无论他们做什么其他志愿工作，
just have a better time doing it. Yeah, it was an awesome talk. I can definitely recommend. I mean, there's so many highlights. You really talk about personal stuff, and it's a different kind of talk. One of my favorite points that you made, though, is that, you know, people mistake your sort of expertise in the Veeam, which is the VM that, for those that don't know,
都能在这个过程中过得更开心。是的，这是一个精彩的演讲。我绝对要推荐。有很多亮点。你真正谈论了个人经历，这是一场与众不同的演讲。不过我最喜欢的观点之一是，人们误以为你对 Beam（就是那个虚拟机，对那些不知道的人来说，
that, you know, languages like Elixir and Erlang run on. They figured, oh, like, you must have been an expert before you started building Benchy. Anyways, I'll let you finish the rest, because that was one of my favorite parts. It's like, that's a great learning lesson for folks that are, you know, want to get to that level, but think, oh, I'm not an expert. So yeah, essentially people come up and say, oh, you need to have known all of this about
像 Elixir 和 Erlang 这样的语言就是在它上面运行的）有很深的专业知识。他们会想，哦，在创建 Benchy 之前，你一定就已经是个专家了。总之，我让你讲完剩下的部分，因为那是我最喜欢的部分之一。这就像是，对于那些想要达到那个水平却觉得自己“哦，我不是专家”的人来说，这是一个很好的学习教训。所以，本质上人们会走过来对我说，“哦，你必须事先了解所有这些关于
it. And it's like, no, no, no. The relationship is inverse. I didn't know anything about it, but I started writing this benchmarking library. And in order to write it and write it well, I needed to learn about the BNB. And that's why I became so good at knowing it. So that's both, you know, how time measurements work, how processes and memory measurement work. So, for instance, there's a very fun story where, like, we tried to introduce memory measurements in Benchy. So, like, see, like, how much memory consumption does this one function I take, that I run, take, basically. And it took us months to figure it out because we needed to realize that the beam vm loses generational garbage collection and like where do they hide the values and stuff and if
它的知识。”而事实是，不，不，不。这种关系是倒过来的。我对此一无所知，但我开始编写这个基准测试库。为了把它写出来并且写好，我需要去了解 Beam 虚拟机。这就是为什么我后来对它如此精通。所以无论是时间测量如何工作，还是进程和内存测量如何工作，都是如此。比如，有一个非常有趣的趣事，我们在 Benchy 中尝试引入内存测量——比如，查看我运行的这个函数到底消耗了多少内存。我们花了几个月的时间才弄明白，因为我们需要意识到 Beam 虚拟机使用的是分代垃圾回收，以及它们把值藏在哪里之类的，如果
you're interested in that my co-maintainer devin estes actually gave a very great talk about that very many times about like how memory measurement works in the beam that was just the result of us you know doing that work and figuring that out and so it's uh very fun so like yeah if you want to learn something you know go work on it you don't need to know where to work on it you work on it and then you get better at it and you become an expert maybe awesome perfect piece of advice to end on
你对此感兴趣，我的共同维护者 Devin Estes 实际上关于这个主题做过非常精彩的演讲，讲了很多次关于内存测量如何在 Beam 中运作的内容，这正是我俩做这项工作并把它搞清楚的结果。所以这非常有趣——如果你想学点什么，去干就行了，你不需要一开始就知道该从哪里入手，你直接动手去做，然后你就会变得更擅长，也许最后就成了专家。太棒了，一个完美的结束建议。
and we will link in the show notes the talk that you just mentioned that Devin gave if folks want to go watch that and as well we'll link your talk once it comes online thanks for being interviewed thank you very much Connor alright we've now migrated to the lunchroom. We're here with Kim Housing. Close enough. Close enough. Kim Housing. Kim Housing. You work at IMG Arena, and you're here as an attendee. Tell us, how has the conference been? It's day two of the two-day conference.
我们将在节目简介中附上你刚才提到的 Devin 的演讲链接，如果大家想去观看的话；同时，一旦你的演讲上线，我们也会附上链接。谢谢你接受采访。非常感谢 Connor。好的，我们现在转移到了餐厅。我们和 Kim Housing 在一起。差不多。差不多。Kim Housing。Kim Housing。你在 IMG Arena 工作，你这次是以与会者的身份来的。告诉我们，大会感觉怎么样？今天是两天大会的第二天。
How's it been? Favorite talks? It's been great. It's been great. It's very technical, very theoretical, which I love. Lots of great people, lots of great talks. Yeah, good vibes. And I guess, well, yours was clearly one of my favorites about combinators. Very, very interesting. Yeah. Tell us a little bit about yourself. Where are you from? What languages do you use day to day? And if you want, tell us a little bit about yourself. Where are you from? What languages do you use day to day? And if you want, tell us a little bit what you do for work. Yeah. So I'm a Scala developer with IMG Arena. I have five years experience as a Scala developer, before which I did various other things.
感觉如何？最喜欢哪些演讲？太棒了。太棒了。非常技术化，非常理论化，我非常喜欢。有很多优秀的人，有很多精彩的演讲。氛围很好。我想，你的那场关于组合子的演讲显然是我的最爱之一。非常非常有趣。给我们简单介绍一下你自己。你来自哪里？你日常使用什么语言？如果你愿意的话，给我们简单介绍一下你自己。你来自哪里？你日常使用什么语言？如果你愿意的话，简单介绍一下你的工作。好的。我是 IMG Arena 的一名 Scala 开发者。我有五年的 Scala 开发经验，在此之前我做过各种其他的事情。
And at IMG, I work in Scala and I also do random tasks. I have a passion for Regex and AWK. And I do a bit of infrastructure. Yeah, just various things to keep busy. But yeah, Scala is my bread and butter. If you had to recommend people between checking out Scala or AUK, what do you love about AUK? Why is that one of your personal passions? Because it's super, super fast,
在 IMG，我使用 Scala 工作，也会做一些杂七杂八的任务。我对 Regex（正则表达式）和 AWK 充满热情。我还做一点基础设施方面的工作。是的，就是各种各样的事情来保持忙碌。不过，Scala 是我的看家本领。如果要你在 Scala 和 AWK 之间推荐一个让大家去了解的语言，你最喜欢 AWK 的什么？为什么这是你的个人热情所在？因为它是超级超级快的，
and it combines some of my favorite things, which are words and logic. So what's better, Scala or AUC? If you only had to choose one, or if you had to recommend folks to go check out a language, which one do you recommend? I would recommend Scala, because you can do everything with Scala.
它结合了我最喜欢的一些东西，那就是文字和逻辑。那么哪个更好，Scala 还是 AWK？如果你只能选择一个，或者如果你必须向大家推荐一门语言，你推荐哪一个？我会推荐 Scala，因为你可以用 Scala 做任何事情。
You cannot do everything with AUC. But yeah, for certain things, it can be really good and especially if you want to do like some data manipulation in the cloud or something it's a very good choice. Awesome and is this your first time attending Lambda Days or have you been here before? It's my first time here, yeah. You think you'll be back?
你不能用 AWK 做所有事情。但是，对于某些事情来说，它真的非常好，特别是如果你想在云端做一些数据处理之类的工作，它是一个非常好的选择。太棒了。这是你第一次参加 Lambda Days 还是以前来过？这是我第一次来这里。你觉得你还会再来吗？
I think I will. Awesome thanks for being on the podcast. Alright, thank you. We are here with Alexis King closing keynote of day one of Lambda Days 2023. Introduce yourself, because most of the listeners probably operate in the systems space, so some people know who you are, even though you're very well-known in the Haskell community. So introduce sort of where you're from, what you're working on, and maybe we'll talk a bit about the keynote that you gave yesterday, which was awesome, by the way.
我想我会的。太棒了，谢谢你来参加播客。好的，谢谢。我们现在和 Alexis King 在一起，她是 2023 年 Lambda Days 第一天闭幕主题演讲的嘉宾。自我介绍一下吧，因为大多数听众可能都在系统领域工作，所以虽然你在 Haskell 社区非常有名，但有些人可能不知道你是谁。所以介绍一下你来自哪里，你正在做什么，也许我们还会聊聊你昨天做的主题演讲，顺便说一句，那场演讲太棒了。
Wow. You're just... I feel like I'm talking to a news reporter. But yeah, I feel like I'm talking to a news reporter. But yeah, I'm Alexis King. I work for a company called Tweak at the moment, and I work on GHC, Pascal Compiler. And currently, I've been working on improving the compile time performance of GHC. But I've also, in the past, which I was speaking on today, was delimited continuations, added delimited continuations to the GHC RTS, which is exciting. Of course, it probably doesn't mean very much to most people because delimited continuations are a mystery to most people, but that's the whole
哇。你简直……我觉得我像是在和一个新闻记者对话。不过，我觉得我像是在和一个新闻记者对话。但话说回来，我是 Alexis King。我目前在一家名为 Tweak 的公司工作，我从事 GHC（Haskell 编译器）的工作。目前，我一直在致力于改进 GHC 的编译时间性能。不过过去我也做过一些工作，也就是我今天演讲的内容，是将定界延续（delimited continuations）添加到了 GHC RTS 中，这很令人兴奋。当然，这对大多数人来说可能没有太大意义，因为定界延续对大多数人来说是个谜，但这正是
reason I gave this talk. So if you're interested, you can watch the talk. The talk was absolutely phenomenal. We'll talk about how beautiful the slides were in a second, but give people maybe, I'm not even sure, is it possible to give like a 30 second overview of what people can expect from this amazing Delimited Continuations talk? Because not only was it beautiful, but I think it's probably going to be the most approachable talk. Not that there's been too many talks given on Delimited Continuations, but what can maybe a 30 second high level as best you can? Because it's a hairy topic to try and summarize in a little podcast bite. Yeah, so I mean, I think really the sort of core concept that delimited continuations are really about is this ability to suspend and then later resume computations. And the sort of discussion of exactly how that happens is complicated,
我做这个演讲的全部原因。如果你感兴趣，可以去观看这个演讲。那场演讲绝对是现象级的。我们待会儿再谈幻灯片有多美，不过能给听众们——甚至我自己都不确定，是否有可能用 30 秒左右的时间概述一下大家能从这个精彩的定界延续演讲中期待些什么？因为不仅幻灯片很美，而且我想这可能是最平易近人的演讲了。倒不是说关于定界延续已经有了太多的演讲，但你能用 30 秒左右的高层次概括一下吗？因为要在短短的播客片段里总结这样一个复杂晦涩的主题实在很难。好的，我的意思是，我认为真正让定界延续成为核心概念的是这种能够暂停然后稍后恢复计算的能力。而关于这具体是如何发生的讨论是复杂的，
but the talk goes into the detail and sort of perhaps at times painfully exquisite detail about exactly how that happens. But the interesting thing about it is that you can use them to implement all these common types of weird, fancy control operators that show up in programming languages like
但演讲深入探讨了细节，并且以一种有时甚至是痛苦般精致的细节，准确地解释了这一切是如何发生的。但有趣的是，你可以用它们来实现编程语言中出现的所有这些常见类型的诡异、花哨的控制操作符，
generators, coroutines, exceptions. And that's really what they're about. Awesome. So we will link your keynote. I'm not actually sure. I think if I remember correctly, the Lambda Days 2022 talks, they took a few months to come out.
比如生成器、协程、异常。这才是它们的真正意义所在。太棒了。所以我们会附上你的主题演讲链接。其实我不太确定。如果我没记错的话，Lambda Days 2022 的演讲视频花了好几个月才发布。
I think it was four to six months. So unfortunately, folks are listening to this in the middle of June. Actually, I will be giving the talk again in about a week at Zurich Hack. And I think the Zurich Hack talks, they normally get them up pretty quickly, so maybe you can link that one. Okay, awesome.
我想是四到六个月。所以不幸的是，听众们听到这期节目时正值六月中旬。实际上，我大约一周后会在 Zurich Hack（苏黎世黑客松）再次做这个演讲。我想 Zurich Hack 的演讲视频通常发布得非常快，所以也许你可以附上那个链接。好的，太棒了。
Also, too, I didn't know Zurich Hack. That's Z or Z, depending on what country you're in, U-R-I, so like the first four letters of Zurich, and then Hack, H-A-C. I didn't even know this existed, and I'm a pretty prolific talk watcher. Tell us a little bit. What is Zurich Hack?
另外，我以前也不知道 Zurich Hack。那是 Z-U-R，取决于你在哪个国家，或者是 Z，U-R-I，也就是 Zurich 的前四个字母，然后是 Hack，H-A-C。我甚至不知道这个活动的存在，而我可是个非常高产的演讲观看者。给我们介绍一下吧。什么是 Zurich Hack？
How come I didn't know about it? And what can people expect from this kind of conference? It's free, right? It is free. So how do you know that it's free if you didn't know about it? I found out this morning from Meow. Hope you're listening, Meow. I'm not actually sure I'm pronouncing that exactly correct.
为什么我以前不知道？大家对这种大会有什么期待？它是免费的，对吧？它是免费的。那既然你之前不知道，你是怎么知道它是免费的呢？我今天早上从 Meow 那里听说的。希望你在听，Meow。其实我不太确定我这个发音是否完全正确。
But Meow said, it's a shame you're not going to Zuri Zurich because you've flown all the way over here from Toronto, Canada. And then it was in that moment that I realized I'm actually flying to Zurich on Sunday and I'm taking a week off for vacation and I'm going to be in Switzerland for a week. The first two days of which Sunday and Monday, I will be in Zurich. So serendipitously, and I was like, how is it too late to sign up? And he said, it's free. So that is, that's how I know it's free. So maybe I'll see you at ZuriHack. But yes, I have no idea what the conference is about. I learned about it yesterday and I learned that it was free this morning.
但 Meow 说：“真遗憾你没去苏黎世（Zuri Zurich），因为你从加拿大多伦多一路飞到了这里。”就在那个瞬间，我意识到我其实周日就要飞往苏黎世，我请了一周的假去度假，我将在瑞士待上一周。前两天，也就是周日和周一，我会在苏黎世。所以纯属机缘巧合，当时我就想，现在报名是不是太晚了？他说这是免费的。所以，这就是我怎么知道它是免费的。所以也许我会在 ZuriHack 见到你。但是，是的，我对这个大会到底是什么一无所知。我昨天才听说它，今天早上才听说它是免费的。
So tell the listeners what they can expect from the conference. All right, yeah. So I mean, it's sort of a hybrid. People give some talks, but then there's also like a hackathon component, which is the hack part of ZuriHack. And normally people, I mean, it's pretty casual.
所以给听众们讲讲大家可以对这个大会有什么期待吧。好的，可以。所以我的意思是，它有点像个混合体。人们会做一些演讲，但也有黑客松（hackathon）环节，也就是 ZuriHack 的“Hack”部分。通常大家，我的意思是，它相当休闲。
I actually have never been in person. I spoke at it three years ago, which was when I signed up. I was going to be in person, but then something happened. So I'm excited to be there. But my understanding is that it's normally pretty chill. People will just kind of propose some projects. You can pitch in if you want. You can do your own thing, just chat with people. I'll probably honestly spend a lot of the time just talking to people, but it should be fun. And there's also a few people presenting, obviously myself included. And, yeah, it should just be a pleasant time. Lastly, maybe I'll ask, you've given a ton of talks in the past at a plethora of conferences,
我其实从来没有去过线下。三年前我曾在那儿做过演讲，当时我报了名。我本该去线下的，但后来出了一些状况。所以我很高兴能去那里。据我了解，通常那里挺轻松的。大家会提出一些项目想法。如果你愿意，你可以参与进去。你也可以做你自己的事情，或者只是跟别人聊聊天。老实说，我可能大部分时间都会用来和大家聊天，但这应该会很有趣。当然也会有一些人做演讲，显然也包括我自己在内。而且，是的，这应该是一段愉快的时光。最后，也许我想问，你过去在无数的大会上做过大量的演讲，
many of them highly regarded on the interwebs. Is there a place people can sort of find all of your talks, or if they want to follow you on socials, what's the best way to sort of follow the latest and greatest from Alexis King? That's a good question. I mean, the answer to is there a place that you can find all my talks is no. But if you are interested in following me, I have a blog, which is lexi-lambda.github.io. And also, I'm on Twitter, which is just lexi-lambda, because they don't allow dashes in Twitter usernames. So that's the main place that I post most updates.
其中许多在网络上备受推崇。人们有没有什么地方可以找到你的所有演讲，或者如果他们想在社交媒体上关注你，了解亚历克西斯·金（Alexis King）的最新动态，最好的方式是什么？这是一个好问题。我的意思是，关于“有没有一个地方可以找到我的所有演讲”，答案是没有。但如果你有兴趣关注我，我有一个博客，网址是 lexi-lambda.github.io。此外，我在 Twitter 上的用户名也是 lexi-lambda，因为 Twitter 用户名不允许使用连字符。所以这是我发布大部分更新的主要地方。
The blog, honestly, I haven't written a blog post in two years. Hopefully that will change soon. But there are some things there. People seem to like the ones that I've written in the past. So if you're interested, it's available. Awesome. We will link all of that stuff in the description. Maybe I will compile a list of Alexis's greatest hits and put it in a playlist and link it in the show notes. Thanks for being on the podcast, Alexis. Thank you.
老实说，这个博客我已经两年没写过新文章了。希望这种情况很快会有所改变。不过上面还是有一些内容的。大家似乎挺喜欢我过去写的东西的。所以如果你感兴趣的话，它就在那里。太棒了。我们会在简介中附上所有这些东西。也许我会整理一个 Alexis 精彩演讲的合集，做成一个播放列表并放在节目简介里。谢谢你来到这个播客，Alexis。谢谢你。
We're back because we didn't even talk about how beautiful your slides were. We got carried away with the other content. Tell people quickly, and first, tell people how many slides. This was an hour-long keynote. Tell people how many slides you had and then how you made them because extremely beautiful. And I was halfway through the talk flabbergasted. I was like, there's no way that this was manually created. Something's going on here.
我们回来了，因为我们甚至还没来得及讨论你的幻灯片有多漂亮。我们被其他内容给吸引住了。快告诉大家，首先，告诉大家有多少张幻灯片。这是一个长达一小时的主题演讲。告诉大家你用了多少张幻灯片，以及你是如何制作它们的，因为它们极其精美。我在听演讲听到一半时简直惊呆了。我想，这绝对不可能是手动创建的。这里面肯定有什么门道。
So I think, I mean, if you count every individual step of every slide, there's about 300 distinct steps. If you only count, you know, truly distinct slides, it's 60 slides, which is still a decent number. You know, it's one a minute. So I think that's still pretty decent, pretty respectable. But they're all generated. Racket, the programming language, has a library called Hashlang SlideJaw.
所以我想，如果你计算每一张幻灯片的每一个单独步骤，大概有 300 个不同的步骤。如果你只计算那些真正独立的幻灯片，大概是 60 张幻灯片，这依然是一个相当不错的数字。你知道的，平均一分钟一张。所以我觉得这还是挺体面、挺令人尊敬的。但它们全都是生成的。Racket，这门编程语言，有一个名为 Hashlang SlideJaw 的库。
I mean, I guess it's sort of a language, but really it's just an embedded domain-specific language for making slides. And there's just sort of some primitives for making different types of vector graphics, and then you can compose them together with some combinators, and it's very nice. And, I mean, the truth is, if you just use that library, you can get some decent stuff. But then I've also, over the years, accumulated a set of kind of additional library functions to compose things together. So I'm able to just sort of say, here, I want to have this slide and have these things here. And then I just want to draw an arrow between these two things. And it'll just stick it there.
我的意思是，我想这算是一种语言吧，但实际上它只是一个用于制作幻灯片的嵌入式特定领域语言。里面有一些用于制作不同类型矢量图形的原语，然后你可以用一些组合子将它们组合在一起，这非常棒。而且，老实说，如果你只是使用那个库，你就能做出相当不错的东西。但多年来，我也积累了一套额外的库函数，用来把各种东西组合在一起。所以我能够直接说：在这里，我想要这张幻灯片，并把这些东西放在这里。然后我只想在这两样东西之间画一条箭头。它就会自动把它画好。
And so that's pretty pleasant. And I guess the most fun fact is I was giving a talk on delimited continuations. And my library for staging slides uses delimited continuations internally. So, you know, it's just a fun meta aspect. A fun tidbit of information. So if you're not interested in learning about delimited continuations, but you are interested in how to make beautiful slides, go check out the talk that's linked in the description.
所以这非常令人愉快。我想最有趣的事实是，我当时正在做一个关于定界延续的演讲。而我用来分阶段展示幻灯片的库，其内部恰好就使用了定界延续。所以，你知道的，这只是一个有趣的元编程层面。一个有趣的小知识。所以如果你对学习定界延续不感兴趣，但对如何制作漂亮的幻灯片感兴趣，那就去看看简介中链接的演讲吧。
It uses Hashlang Slideshow from the Racket language. It's a lisp. We check out the talk. It's linked in the description. It uses hash slang, slideshow from the racket language. It's a lisp. We all love lisps. Once again, thanks for being on the pod. Thank you. This is going to be fantastic. All right, we're here once again with another guest, this time special guest, Jose Valim. If you don't know, he is the creator of the Elixir language. Allegedly. Allegedly? Allegedly. What does that mean? Who knows? Who knows? All right, so allegedly the creator
它使用了来自 Racket 语言的 Hashlang Slideshow。它是一种 Lisp。我们去看看那个演讲吧。链接在简介里。它使用了来自 Racket 语言的 hash slang slideshow。它是一种 Lisp。我们所有人都热爱 Lisp。再次感谢你来到播客。谢谢。这将会非常棒。好的，我们再次迎来了另一位嘉宾，这次是特邀嘉宾 Jose Valim。如果你不知道的话，他是 Elixir 语言的创造者。据称。据称？据称。这是什么意思？谁知道呢？谁知道呢？好吧，所以据称是
of the Elixir programming language. You're going to be speaking, I think, not in the next time slot, but two time slots from now, about Livebook, I think? Livebook, yeah. And so maybe give us a little preview of your talk and then tell us how the conference has been so far.
Elixir 编程语言的创造者。我想你接下来要发表演讲，不是在下一个时段，而是在两个时段之后，是关于 Livebook 的吧？Livebook，是的。所以也许能给我们简单透露一下你的演讲内容，然后讲讲到目前为止你对这次大会的感受？
And if you want, tell us what's... I'm asking too many questions. Let's start with a preview of your talk and how the conference has been so far. And if you want, you know, tell us what's, I'm asking too many questions. Let's start with, you know, a preview of your talk and how the conference has been going. Yeah, so my talk is going to be about Livebook, which is, in a way, we want it to be like the next generation of open source computational notebooks. So then there's the follow-up question, which is, what are computational notebooks. And computational notebooks, it's a tool that allows you to have code, documentation, and rich visualizations all living side by side. And my talk is about both, I want to talk about both how Livebook works
如果你愿意的话，告诉我们……我问了太多问题了。让我们从你的演讲预览和目前为止的大会感受开始。如果你愿意，告诉我们——我问了太多问题了。让我们从你的演讲预览以及大会的进展情况开始。好的，所以我的演讲将关于 Livebook，在某种程度上，我们希望它成为下一代开源计算笔记本（computational notebooks）。然后就会随之产生一个问题，那就是什么是计算笔记本。计算笔记本是一个允许你将代码、文档和丰富的可视化效果共存并呈现出来的工具。我的演讲既会探讨 Livebook 是如何工作
and is implemented, but all the different kinds of things and ideas that you can learn once you put documentation, code, and rich visualizations all together. That sounds amazing. I mean, spoiler alert, I've heard you on Thinking Elixir. I think you did like a five back-to-back sort of series, which was amazing. So I've heard a lot of this stuff, but we will link this talk when it comes out online if folks haven't heard about this.
以及被实现的，也会探讨当你把文档、代码和丰富的可视化效果全部融合在一起时，你可以学到的所有各种各样的东西和想法。听起来太棒了。剧透一下，我听过你在 Thinking Elixir 上的节目。我想你当时做了一个连续五期的系列节目，太棒了。所以我听过很多这样的内容，但当这个演讲在线上发布时，我们会附上链接，如果大家还没听说过的话。
It's amazing stuff. I've also seen your keynote that I believe happened in the pandemic where you launched NX. So, I mean, there's so much exciting stuff. Like, what is the 30,000-foot view of all the exciting stuff that's happening in Elixir in the past couple years? So, it's kind of hard to answer the question because there are... So, I'd like to say that... So, one of my recent talks was called my future with elixir because i wanted well i am the creator of the language and i
这真是太棒了。我也看过你的主题演讲，我记得那是在疫情期间，你在会上推出了 NX。所以，有这么多令人兴奋的事情。过去几年里，在 Elixir 发生的所有令人兴奋的事情中，从 30,000 英尺的高空俯瞰，整体图景是怎样的？所以，这个问题有点难回答，因为有……所以，我喜欢说……所以，我最近的一次演讲被称为“我与 Elixir 的未来”，因为我想——我是这门语言的创造者，我
am aware that what i think for elixir is going to impact a lot of people but i also want everybody in the community everybody in the community they also have their relation with the language and what is their future and what they expect so i'm always very wary of like trying to answer about elixir because i wish that is not a individual answer but a collective answer like a lot of people want something and want they're going to have their different uh-feet view version. So my version is the things that I've been excited about is machine learning, bringing a lot of the machine learning ideas into Elixir. So today, that's one of the things I'm going to show in my talk, like how quickly you can have speech-to-text machine learning model
深知我对 Elixir 的想法将对许多人产生影响，但我也希望社区中的每个人，社区中的每个人，他们也与这门语言有着自己的关系，关心他们的未来以及他们的期望。所以我总是非常谨慎地试图去代表 Elixir 做回答，因为我希望这不是一个人的回答，而是一个集体的回答——很多人想要某些东西，他们会有自己不同版本的宏观视角。所以我的版本是让我感到兴奋的事情，比如机器学习，将许多机器学习的理念引入 Elixir。所以今天，这也是我将在演讲中展示的内容之一，展示你在 Livebook 中结合 Elixir，能以多快的速度运行语音转文本的机器学习模型。
running Livebook with Elixir. And then you can get that, bring it to a web application and deploy to production. So that's one. But also related to Livebook, I'm also thinking a lot about improving the whole developer experience and the user experience of the language. And then the other thing like of what is happening with elixir that i am working on is we are exploring bringing a type system to elixir but there are a lot of questions like do we want to do it do we not want to do it and if we do it what does that mean but that's kind of
然后你可以获取这个模型，将它带到 Web 应用中并部署到生产环境中。这是其一。同样与 Livebook 相关的是，我还在思考如何改进整个开发体验和语言的用户体验。我在 Elixir 上正在做的另一件正在探索的事情是，我们正在探索为 Elixir 引入类型系统。但这里有很多问题：我们想做吗？我们不想做吗？如果我们做了，这意味着什么？但这大概就是正在发生的一切的总结，从我个人的角度以及让我感到兴奋的事情的角度来看。但如果你去问别人，他们会对 Phoenix 或 Membrane 在 Elixir 社区中发生的事情有他们自己感到兴奋的东西。太棒了，我会把所有这些东西以及你提到的那场演讲（即 Elixir 的未来）都放在节目简介里，如果大家想去观看的话。我知道这并不是你第一次来 Lambda Days，你以前来过多少次？是什么让今年变得特别？是的，实际上，我不确定我来过多少次，因为我——所以这个活动在克拉科夫，
like a summary of everything that is happening and from my point of view and my the point of view of what i'm excited about but if you ask somebody else they're going to have like their own things that are excited about phoenix or membrane uh happening in the elixir community awesome i will link all of the things plus the talk that you mentioned it was the future of elixir in the show notes so folks want to go watch it i know this isn't your first lambda days how many times have have you been before and what makes this year special? Yeah, I actually, I'm not sure how many times I have been here because I, so the event is in Krakow
就像是对正在发生的一切的一个总结，从我的角度以及我所兴奋的事物的角度出发。但如果你问其他人，他们也会有他们自己在 Elixir 社区中对 Phoenix 或 Membrane 等事物感到兴奋的地方。太棒了，我会把所有的东西以及你提到的那场演讲（即 Elixir 的未来）链接到shownotes中，所以如果大家想去观看的话——我知道这已经不是你第一次参加 Lambda Days 了，你之前来过多少次？是什么让今年变得特别？是的，实际上，我不确定我来过这里多少次，因为这个活动是在克拉科夫举办的
and I live super close to Krakow, like 20 minutes by train. So I think I was here in, I may be like the most frequent speaker, but citation needed. We did not check that yet because i'm super close and then i sometimes they invite me sometimes i invite myself i like hey i have this idea can i come and present and uh when for some reason i had nothing to speak about uh they would
而我住得离克拉科夫超级近，坐火车只要 20 分钟。所以我想我在这里——我可能是最经常出席的演讲者，但需要引证。我们还没查过这个，因为我离得超级近，有时他们会邀请我，有时我自己会申请，说“嘿，我有这个想法，我能来做个演讲吗？”而当出于某种原因我没什么可讲的时候，他们也会
invite me to come and attend and just hang out which is super cool so so yeah and and uh i'm really happy that uh it's like the 10 years of lambda days and it's really interesting because it's also like last year was also 10 years of elixir so it's all like so close to each other and like uh um you know related and about the same age in certain ways that is awesome i had no idea so maybe potentially you know we won't say it too loud but maybe this is secretly like you know an elixir conf conf you know i know they talk about other languages but but really they started at the same time there seems seems to be something there yeah no i think uh yeah uh i i i think i don't think elixir is the majority being represented here, but I think that's great.
邀请我来参加并四处逛逛，这真的超级酷。所以，是的，我真的很高兴 Lambda Days 迎来了 10 周年，这真的很有趣，因为这也恰好是 Elixir 的 10 周年，一切都如此接近，并且在某些方面彼此相关、年龄相仿，这太棒了。我完全不知道。所以也许，私下里说，我们别太大声说，也许这 secretly 实际上也是一个 Elixir 峰会？我知道他们谈论其他语言，但实际上它们是同时起步的，这其中似乎有什么联系。是的，不，我认为，是的，我不认为 Elixir 是这里代表性占多数的语言，但我认为这很好。
And it's one of the reasons why I'm frequently speaking here and I try to come every year is exactly because it's a diverse hub. We're talking to Barbara later. We will ask Barbara. She's one of the organizers or the organizer of the conference. We'll ask her what her favorite lang is. And I'll be surprised if she doesn't say Elixir. So we'll see what she says.
这也是我经常在这里演讲并努力每年都来的原因之一，正是因为它是一个多元化的枢纽。我们稍后会采访 Barbara。我们会问问 Barbara。她是大会的组织者之一，或者是组织者。我们会问她最喜欢什么语言。如果她不说 Elixir，我会感到很惊讶。所以我们拭目以待她会说什么。
Last thing, if people want to follow you or the Elixir language, what's the best place or best spot to go to to check out, sort of follow you and follow the language? Well, I am weirdly on Twitter. And, yeah, I think... Actually, I'm not sure. Well, do follow Elixir. So it is on Twitter.
最后，如果人们想关注你或 Elixir 语言，去哪里查看并关注你和这门语言是最好或最理想的去处？嗯，我很奇怪地在用 Twitter。而且，是的，我想……实际上，我也不确定。不过，一定要关注 Elixir。它在 Twitter 上。
We have the Elixir forum. We have a Slack and a bunch of community places where people can join and participate. And I think that's more important than following me. So do that. Awesome. We will end it here. Thank you so much for being on the podcast, José yeah my pleasure she's back for more oh yeah that's right we're gonna get
我们有 Elixir 论坛。我们有一个 Slack 和一堆社区场所，大家可以在那里加入并参与。我认为这比关注我要重要得多。所以去加入吧。太棒了。我们就聊到这里。非常感谢你来到播客，José。好的，我的荣幸。她回来吃更多东西了！哦，对，没错，我们待会儿要去吃
dessert we're gonna get dessert after this maybe is that the only dessert uh there's also some vegan cake sounds sounds vegan um what yeah what what kind of dessert we got here walk us through this kim kim's back and she's got a dessert she's got a dessert. She's got a rubber duck. Is that your rubber duck, Andor? No. It's Kim's rubber duck. So tell us where you got the rubber duck, and tell us what you're snacking on. I got the rubber duck from Evolution Engineering.
甜点，等一下，难道那是唯一的甜点吗？还有一些纯素蛋糕。听起来像是纯素的。嗯，什么，这里有什么甜点？带我们看看这个。Kim 回来了，她拿着甜点。她拿了甜点。她还有一个小黄鸭。那是你的小黄鸭吗，Andor？不是。那是 Kim 的小黄鸭。快告诉我们你是在哪儿拿到这只小黄鸭的，顺便告诉我们你在吃什么零食。这只小黄鸭是 Evolution Engineering 送的。
They have a lot of good merch. And they're a sponsor of the conference. Look at that. You sponsor a conference, you might end up on the pod. And they're hand-in-hand rubber ducks. We love that. And what are you eating dessert-wise? What do we got here? It's a panna cotta and the sauce,
他们有很多很好的周边。而且他们是大会的赞助商。你看。赞助大会，你就有可能上播客。而且它们是手拉手的小黄鸭。我们太喜欢了。那你吃的是什么甜点的？我们这儿有什么？这是一份意式奶冻，酱汁
I think is passion fruit and there's some fresh fruit. It looks delicious. Like if you would let me eat it. Take a bite and we'll do a, we'll do a live feedback on dessert lunch day two. She's nodding her head, thumbs up. We'll wait for her to finish a bite, and then we'll get some verbalization of how it was. It was good. It was excellent. Four out of five. Four out of five stars.
我想是百香果味的，上面还有一些新鲜水果。看起来很好吃。如果你肯让我吃一口的话。咬一口，我们对第二天午餐的甜点做个现场反馈。她在点头，竖起大拇指。我们等她咬完这一口，然后听听她对口感的描述。很好吃。非常棒。五分满分得四分。
You heard it here first. Dessert. Not the vegan cake, but the panna cotta. All right. We're here with our next interviewee, another speaker and or spoke yesterday about dependent types. We'll talk about your talk in a sec. First, introduce yourself, where you're from, where you're working from, and we'll go from there.
你在这里最先听到了。甜点。不是纯素蛋糕，而是意式奶冻。好的。我们迎来了下一位受访者，另一位演讲者 Andor，他昨天发表了关于依赖类型的演讲。我们一会儿再聊你的演讲。首先，请自我介绍一下，你来自哪里，你在哪里工作，然后我们继续。
Okay. Hi. My name is Andor. I'm originally from Hungary. I work for Standard Chartered. I live in Nottingham. I'm interested in type theory, dependent types, functional programming in general. I would like to create programs which works.
好的。嗨。我叫 Andor。我原本来自匈牙利。我为渣打银行工作。我住在诺丁汉。我对类型理论、依赖类型以及整体的函数式编程感兴趣。我想编写能正常运行的程序。
I like to create programs that works. That's a quote. Well, maybe that'll be the cold open right there. So tell us a bit at your job, what language are you operating in? What's your daily driver? And then we'll talk a bit about your talk. My daily job is a Haskell job. I basically send that chart.
我喜欢编写能正常运行的程序。这是一句名言。好吧，也许这会成为开场白。那么给我们讲讲你的工作，你使用的是什么语言？你日常使用的是什么？然后我们再聊聊你的演讲。我的日常工作是 Haskell 相关的工作。我在渣打银行。
It has a very specialized Haskell team, and I'm part of that. Awesome. So Haskell being used in the wild. Absolutely love that. Haskell, one of my top five favorite programming languages. You gave a talk yesterday on dependent types. We will link that in the description for folks that want to go check it out. Give us a little overview of what you talked about. Dependent types are kind of interesting and easy concepts, but we are kind of demonizing them, saying that, oh, these are hard, because if GHC type level programming is hard, then dependent type programming must be harder.
那里有一个非常专门的 Haskell 团队，我是其中一员。太棒了。Haskell 正在实际生产环境中被使用。我绝对喜欢这样。Haskell 是我最喜欢的五大编程语言之一。你昨天做了一个关于依赖类型的演讲。我们会在简介中附上链接，供想去了解的人观看。给我们简单介绍一下你讲的内容吧。依赖类型是一个挺有趣且简单的概念，但我们有点妖魔化它们，说“哦，这些很难”，因为如果 GHC 类型级别的编程很难，那么依赖类型编程一定更难。
And my hobby is actually try to reach a consensus or try to show that dependent types are actually easy, easier than normal type level programming in Haskell. Awesome. So you are trying to find use cases in the wild that are actually, you know, applied dependent types. Is that correct? Yes, exactly.
而我的爱好实际上是试图达成共识，或者试图证明依赖类型其实很简单，比 Haskell 中正常的类型级别编程还要简单。太棒了。所以你正试图在实际生产环境中寻找真正被应用的依赖类型的用例？是这样吗？是的，完全正确。
And my strategy here is like, first I read the type-driven development from Edwin Brady. That was a really good book. And after I just, let's just grab another book from my bookshelf and try to apply dependent types there and see where is actually, there are the sweet spots. There are the sweet spots that try to apply dependent types there and see where is actually there are the sweet spots where are the sweet spots that are actually dependent types make sense
我的策略是：首先我读了 Edwin Brady 写的《类型驱动开发》（Type-Driven Development）。那是一本非常好的书。之后我只是——让我们从书架上再拿一本书，试着在那里应用依赖类型，看看真正的甜蜜点（sweet spots）在哪里。寻找那些真正让依赖类型变得有意义的甜蜜点
and i we don't overdo it it's not painful it's more like it's helping us awesome if people want to learn more about dependent pipes slash follow you on the socials what's the best way for folks to do that i have a twitter account that we can we can link that awesome we will link that in the show notes anything else you want to say? Is this your first time to Lambda Days? Have you been here before? What are your thoughts about the conference? This is a really good conference.
而且我们并没有过度，这并不是痛苦的，更像是它在帮助我们。太棒了，如果人们想了解更多关于 dependent pipes 的信息或者在社交媒体上关注你，最好的方式是什么？我有一个 Twitter 账号，我们可以把它链接起来。太棒了，我们会在节目笔记中附上链接。还有什么想说的吗？这是你第一次来 Lambda Days 吗？你以前来过吗？你对这个会议有什么看法？这是一个非常好的会议。
I really like this conference because it's not really language-specific. Previously, I always attended Haskell conferences, and now this is my first real functional programming conference in the sense that there are many functional programming languages. This is something fresh for languages. And this is something fresh for me. And this is my first time at Lambda Days. You think you'll be back in the future to Lambda Days 2024 or some version in the future? Definitely. Awesome. Thanks for being on the podcast. Cheers. We're back with Kim. We are going to hopefully find Becca, who gave a lightning
我真的很喜欢这个会议，因为它并不是真正针对特定语言的。以前，我总是参加 Haskell 会议，而现在这是我第一次真正意义上的函数式编程会议，因为这里有许多函数式编程语言。这对语言来说是耳目一新的。这对我也很新鲜。这也是我第一次参加 Lambda Days。你觉得你以后还会来 Lambda Days 2024 或是未来的某个版本吗？一定会的。太棒了。谢谢你来参加播客。干杯。我们和 Kim 一起回来了。我们希望找到 Becca，她之前做了一个关于函数式女性的闪电演讲，之后我们将深入探讨函数式女性。但现在我们和 Kim 在一起，她提到她是函数式女性组织的成员。我不确定是以组织者还是成员的身份。所以给我们讲讲函数式女性，以及其他会议如何参与其中或让他们参与到会议中。好的，所以我不是组织者。Becca 和 Liv 是组织者，功劳归于她们。她们在筹办方面做得非常出色。这个组织非常非常新。它大约在两个月前启动。
talk on functional females later to talk more about functional females. But here we are standing with Kim, and she mentions she's a part of the functional females organization. I'm not sure as an organizer or as a member. So tell us a bit about functional females and how other conferences can get involved or have them involved in their conference. Okay, so I am not an organizer. Becca and Liv are the organizers, full credit to them. They did a great job setting it up. It's very, very new. It launched about two months ago.
而且我是 Scala 社区的社区负责人。很有趣。这是一个全球性组织，还是主要在欧洲？因为在我参加今天和昨天的会议之前，我从来没听说过他们。是的，到目前为止，我认为所有成员都在欧洲。到目前为止，大约有 70 名女性，她们使用各种函数式编程语言，而且目前都位于欧洲。
And I am a community lead for the Scala community. Interesting. And is this a global organization or is it based mostly in Europe? Because I'd never heard about them before attending this conference today and yesterday. Yeah, so far, I think all the members are Europe-based. It's about 70 women so far that work in various functional programming languages and so far are all based in Europe.
但我认为位于欧洲并不是一个硬性要求。很有趣。所以，我主要是 C++ 社区的成员。函数式女性会有兴趣涉足 C++ 吗？因为我们也有一些函数式的东西。或者你们是想坚守 Lambda Days、ZuriHack 等等，我不知道，所有的函数式会议。函数式女性的主要愿景是什么？
But I don't think it's a requirement to be based in Europe. Interesting. So I'm primarily a member of the C++ community. Would functional females be interested in entering C++? Because we got some functional stuff. Or are you guys trying to stick to the Lambda Days, ZuriHack, I don't know, all the functional conferences. What's the main vision of functional females?
是的，据我所知，我们对 C++ 真的不太感兴趣。到目前为止，Scala 是我们最大的群体。所以我们非常专注于 Scala 活动。
Yeah, as far as I know, we're not really into C++. We have Scala as the largest group so far. So we're very focused on Scala events. into C++. Scala is the largest group so far, so we're very focused on Scala events. Also Elixir and Rust. And yeah, just functional conferences like this one. Wait, you guys are interested in Rust,
不仅是 Scala，还包括 Elixir 和 Rust。是的，还有像这样的函数式会议。等等，你们对 Rust 感兴趣，但对 C++ 不感兴趣？这到底是怎么回事？去跟 Becca 和 Liv 谈谈吧。我们会找到 Becca 和 Liv，并弄清楚事情的真相。好的，谢谢 Kim 第三次来参加播客。好好享受剩下的甜点吧。非常感谢。我总是忍不住再来。好的，我们在这里，我们回来了。
but not C++? What's going on here? Talk to Becca and Liv. We will find Becca and Liv, and we will get to the bottom of this, folks. All right, thanks, Kim, for being on the pod for the third time. Enjoy the rest of your dessert. Thank you so much. I just keep coming back for more. All right, we're here, we're back.
我们正在采访 Lambda Days 2023 的第二天。我们和 Pierre 在一起。我发音准确吗？Pierre。Pierre。不过我也听 Pierre 的。你听吗？因为说这种语言的人说 Pierre。
We're interviewing Lambda Days 2023, day two. We're here with Pierre. Am I pronouncing that correctly? Pierre. Pierre. But I listen to Pierre, too. You listen? Because the language speakers say Pierre.
这比我前几个小时一直叫你的 Peter 要好……一切都行。一切都行。Pierre，Peter，随便啦。好的。所以大多数人可能不认识你。介绍一下你自己。你来自哪里？你在哪家公司工作？
It's better than Peter that I was calling you for, like, the first couple hours when I... Everything works. Everything works. Pierre, Peter, whatever. All right. So most of the folks won't know you. Introduce yourself. Where are you from? What company do you work for?
你主要在从事什么技术？所以，全名是 Peer Stritzinger，这也是我公司的名字。我们基本上是在硬件上直接运行 Erlang。这也是我过去多次在这里做演讲的内容。而这次我很懒，没有时间做演讲。我只是，只是到处闲逛。你今天确实做了一个闪电演讲。你并不是完全偷懒。
And sort of what technologies are you working with? So, yeah, the whole name is Peer Stritzinger, which is also the name of my company. And we basically run Erlang directly on hardware. And that's what I've been presenting on here several times in the past. And this time I was lazy and didn't have the time to talk. And I'm just, just like hanging around. You did give a lightning talk today. You wasn't completely lazy.
给我们讲讲你在闪电演讲中谈了什么。在闪电演讲中，我只是给出了 GRISP 的路线图，我们正在做什么。基本上，我们构建硬件来实际运行，让其他人更容易在硬件上运行它。这样我们就能提供更好的用户体验。我给出了接下来要推出的东西的路线图，比如我们正在构建以插入主板的小型硬件传感器模块，电池板，比如充电器板，还有 GRISP Zero，这将是新东西，它将是运行完整 Erlang 虚拟机最小的东西。
Tell us what you talked about in the lightning talk. In the lightning talk I just gave the GRISP roadmap, what we're up to. Basically so we build hardware to actually run, make it easier for other people to run it on the hardware. So we can actually provide a better user experience. And I gave the roadmap of the next things to come, like little hardware sensor modules
如果我没记错的话，你在演讲中提到 Zero 的灵感来自于树莓派 Zero，我对它了解不多。那么它们之间有什么区别？或者树莓派和 Grisp 之间有什么可比性，还是它们完全不同？完全不同。
that we are building to plug into the main board, a battery board, like a charger board, and also GRISP Zero, which will be the new thing, which will be the smallest thing that will be running the full-blown Erlang VM. And if I recall correctly in the talk, you mentioned that the Xero was inspired by the Raspberry Pi Xero, which I don't know much about. So what's the sort of difference? Or is there a comparison between the Raspberry Pi and Grisp, or are they completely different? Not at all.
我只是借用了这个名字。所以请给我们多讲讲 Grisp。如果人们有兴趣购买这个硬件，它是人们可以用于业余项目的，还是被大公司使用的？人们用这个硬件做什么？所以硬件和软件栈，因为软件栈其实是更重要的东西。
I just sold the name. And so tell us a bit more about Grisp. So if people are interested in acquiring this hardware, is it something that people can use for hobby projects, or is it used by sort of big companies? What do folks use the hardware for? So the hardware and the software stack, because the software stack is actually the more important thing.
硬件只是一个用来实际尝试的评估板。据我所知，它被工业界使用，主要是我们自己，也用于开发我们自己的产品。它被很多大学用于教学，因为对教授来说，不必阅读半篇关于如何让树莓派与 Erlang 配合工作并点亮一个灯的硕士论文会更有趣，因为那总是千篇一律。
The hardware is just an evaluation board to actually try it out. It's used by industry, as I know, mainly by us, also for developing our own products. It's used by a lot of universities for teaching because it's more fun for the professor not to have to read half of the master's thesis about how to get a Raspberry Pi working with Erlang and having a bit switched on because that's always the same.
因为这种“从零到点亮灯”的过程，我们实际上可以在 10 分钟内提供。然后你就可以开始做有趣的事情了。它也被业余爱好者用于各种事情。太棒了。如果人们有兴趣了解这些，我一定会找到链接放在节目笔记中。如果人们对 Erlang 不太了解，
Because this kind of like the zero to blinking light we actually can provide in 10 minutes. And then you start to do fun stuff. And it's also used by hobbyists for all kinds of things. Awesome. So I'll be sure to find links that we can put in the show notes if people are interested in checking this out. If people don't know much about Erlang,
因为我认为我们的大多数听众都在 C++ 领域，请给我们做一个大约 30 秒的 Erlang 概述，以及为什么人们可能对 Erlang 感兴趣而不是 Elixir，因为我们之前采访了 Jose Valim，他是 Elixir 语言的创建者，该语言构建在 BEAM 之上。总之，我让你来谈谈 Erlang 以及为什么人们可能会感兴趣。是的，BEAM 是我们共享的通用虚拟机，
because I think most of our listeners are sort of in the C++ space, give us like a 30-second overview of Erlang and why people might be interested in Erlang and not Elixir, because we talked to Jose Valim earlier, and he's the creator of the Elixir language, which is built on top of the Beam. Anyways, I'll let you talk about Erlang and why people might be interested. Yeah, so the Beam is the common virtual machine that we share,
实际上 Elixir 并不是基于 BEAM，而是基于 Erlang，以及为什么人们可能会感兴趣。是的。BEAM 是我们共享的通用虚拟机。好吧，实际上 Elixir 并不是基于 BEAM，而是基于 Erlang。它运行在 Erlang 之上。所以如果没有 Erlang，就不会有 Elixir。所以 Erlang 基本上是基础技术，是更古老的语言。我不知道。我的意思是，如果你更喜欢 Ruby 语法，就用 Elixir。
where actually Elixir is not like based on the Beam, but actually based on Erlang and why people might be interested. Yeah. So the Beam is the common virtual machine that we share. Well, actually, Elixir is not like based on the Beam, but actually based on Erlang. It's running on top of Erlang. So without Erlang, Elixir would not be there. So Erlang is basically the base technology, the older language. I don't know. I mean, if you like Ruby syntax more, use Elixir.
如果你更喜欢 Prolog 语法，或者不在乎语法，就用 Erlang。它更像是……它是更古老的，但它也更贴近实际虚拟机的运作方式。所以你想使用它的独特卖点，
If you like Prolog syntax more, you don't care about syntax, use Erlang. It's more kind of like... It is older, but it's also more kind of like to the ground what the actual virtual machine does. So the unique selling point why you want to use it,
或者说这两种语言的卖点，在于它是唯一允许实现全容错程序的系统。也就是说，你的软件有 bug，但你的代码仍然在运行和工作。有一个相当大的公司被收购了，那是多少钱，200 亿美元，300 亿美元？我们昨晚还在讨论这个？哦，你是说 WhatsApp？对。哦，它到处都在运行。
or both languages, is it's the only systems that allow full torrent programs. So your software has bugs, but your code keeps running and working. And there's a pretty big company that was acquired, what was it, for $20 billion, $30 billion, that we were talking about last night? Oh, you mean WhatsApp? Yeah. Oh, it's run everywhere.
基本上，曾经有一个估计，95% 的人类通信在某个时刻都会通过运行 Erlang 的系统。这包括所有爱立信基站。所有思科交换机内部都有 Erlang。WhatsApp 内部有 Erlang。然后你可能就已经达到 95% 了。哦，我知道 WhatsApp 的故事。我对其他事情一无所知。
Basically, there was an estimate once that 95% of the human communication goes over a system with Erlang at some point. So that includes all the Ericsson base stations. All Cisco switches have Erlang in them. WhatsApp has Erlang in them. And then probably you're already in 95%. Oh, I knew about the WhatsApp story. I had no idea about the other stuff.
Erlang 被用于许多基础设施中。它隐藏在很多人们不知道的地方，人们确实需要这种鲁棒性。例如，所有银行都使用 Erlang 进行交易。他们只是不谈论它，所以我们不知道。我的意思是，我们在 Erlang 社区知道，但这不是官方的。
Erlang is used for a lot of infrastructure stuff. And it's hidden in a lot of places where people don't know it, where people actually need this robustness. For example, all the banks use Erlang for trading. They just don't talk about it, so we don't know. I mean, we know in the Erlang community, but it's not official.
他们不谈论它。有趣。我得找一些链接放在节目笔记里，因为我对 Erlang 有所了解，但并不知道它在全球范围内被广泛使用。我要问的最后一件事，如果我没记错昨晚的话，你参加 Lambda Days 已经很长时间了，如果不是从一开始的话。是这样吗？我想我错过了第一次。我想我的第一次是第二次，而且在疫情期间有中断，去年我没能参加，但我参加了所有其他的会议。所以你是一个长期与会者，一直回来。
They don't talk about it. Interesting. I'm going to have to find some links to link in the show notes, because I know a little bit about Erlang, but not that it's used globally around the world. Last thing I'll ask, I believe, if I recall correctly from last night, you have been attending Lambda Days for a very long time, if not from the get-go. Is that true? I think I missed the first one. I think my first one was the second one, and there was the break during the pandemic, and I couldn't have attended last year, but I was at all others. And so you've been a longtime attendee, keep coming back.
为什么 Lambda Days 这么棒？如果有人在考虑将来参加 Lambda Days，你会对他们说些什么？我的意思是，如果你对函数式编程感兴趣，或者想了解函数式编程，因为这两种情况都非常适用，Lambda Days 是一个非常好的去处。这是一个很棒的会议。他们有如此棒的内容。我每次回家都会带着灵感。这不像是一个理论会议，比如 ICFP，函数式编程那种学术会议。
Why is Lambda Day so awesome? And if someone's thinking about coming to Lambda Days in the future, what would you tell them? I mean, if you are into functional programming or you want to find out about functional programming, because both work very well, Lambda Place is a very good place to be. It's a great conference. They have so great content. I always come home with ideas. And it's not like a theoretic conference, like ICFP, functional programming, like academic conference.
这里融合了学术内容和工业界内容，我认为这就是这里的优势所在。而且，克拉科夫是一个非常适合旅游的城市。克拉科夫非常美丽，我可以证实这一点。最后一件事，如果人们想在网上、在社交媒体上关注你，有什么最好的途径吗？嗯，我在 Twitter 上。Twitter 账号，我的个人 Twitter 账号是 PRSTR，
There's academic stuff and industry stuff mixed, and I think that's the strength here. And also, Krakow is a very nice city to go to. Krakow is very beautiful, I can confirm. Last thing, if people want to follow you online, on the socials, is there a best place that they can do that? Well, I'm on Twitter. Twitter handle, my personal Twitter handle is PRSTR,
而 Grisp 板基本上在，或者说 GRISP 项目在 grisp org。也在 Twitter 上？也在 Twitter 上。你也可以通过 GRISP 的网站等找到我。太棒了。我会在节目笔记中链接所有这些内容。非常感谢你来到播客。谢谢。请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目笔记，或者访问 adsbthepodcast.com 获取我们提到的任何事物的链接，包括所有的演讲和资源，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，
and the Grisp board is basically on, or the GRISP project is on GRISP org. On Twitter as well? On Twitter as well. And you will also find me via the website of GRISP and whatever. Awesome. I will link all of that stuff in the show notes. Thanks so much for being on the pod. Thank you. Be sure to check the show notes, either in your podcast app or at adsbthepodcast.com for links to any of the things we mentioned, including all of the talks and resources, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion
如果你对今天的节目有任何评论、问题或想法。再次感谢所有同意在 Lambda Days 接受采访的人。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
if you have any comments, questions, or thoughts on today's episode. And once again, thank you to everyone who agreed to be interviewed at Lambda Days. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目评论